[موسيقى]
لست متأكدًا حقًا من مصدر
فكرة البيت الزجاجي ، أعني أننا
أشخاص
عاديون جدًا أحببناهم حقًا مثل الأرض المفتوحة
والتلال المتدحرجة في بعض الغابات ، فقد
ذكرني كثيرًا بالمكان الذي نشأت فيه في
السويد  مثل إحساس مختلف تمامًا
بالحرية والمساحة والانفتاح
والقدرة على الرؤية أمر رائع ولكن هذا
يعني أيضًا أنه يمكن للناس أن يروا في
الفضاء لذا فإن أحد الأشياء التي كانت
مهمة جدًا بالنسبة لنا هو كيفية
تحديد موقع المنزل بالإضافة إلى  وجود
صندوق حجري يكون أكثر خصوصية تحته في
الصندوق الزجاجي في الأعلى ، نستخدم
التضاريس لفرز مناظر الكتلة ،
إحدى صفات الزجاج هي الشفافية
التي تكون لطيفة عندما تكون داخل
المنزل ولكن إحدى الصفات الأخرى هي
الانعكاس  وغالبًا عندما يكون لديك الكثير
من الضوء على السطح الخارجي للمنزل ،
ينتهي بك الأمر برؤية انعكاس
للمناظر الطبيعية بحيث يصبح المنزل
تقريبًا مثل منزل متخفي ،
والقبول المتزايد لتصنيف المنزل الزجاجي
كنموذج معقول  أو
منزل
واحد هو الطريقة التي تطورت بها التكنولوجيا
في أنظمة الزجاج والتحكم في الأظرف
، والآخر هو القبول الاجتماعي
لنمط الحياة العام هذا ، والطابق العلوي
الذي هو منزل زجاجي
يشبه إلى حد ما المنطقة العامة ثم
الطابق السفلي الذي تعرفه  مبنى حجري
به مصاريع مستوحاة من
رحلة إلى جنوب فرنسا حيث
استأجرنا منازل بها مصاريع حديدية كبيرة
واعتقدنا أنه كان رائعًا حقًا
أن نتمكن من إغلاق الستائر عندما
تنام وهو عكس القطبية
مثل  الهيكل الزجاجي في الطابق العلوي ، كان
هدفنا دائمًا هو إنشاء منزل
كان من ناحية تقريبًا مثل
الجوهرة ، ومن ناحية أخرى يكون
مموهًا تمامًا ، فلا يوجد
شيء يجعلنا أكثر فخراً من الوقت الذي سيقود الناس بجواره
ويكونون مثل انتظارك
تمامًا  لقد قمت بعمل هذا المنزل هنا
وشعرت أنه من الجيد أن
نأخذك إلى هناك نوعًا ما ، لذلك هناك
شيء مهم جدًا حول
ذلك وأعتقد أنه أيضًا  الطريقة التي
تريد العائلة أن تعيش بها هي
نوع خاص جدًا من المنزل